hey Tori what do you want to ask him so
Mario ha did you ever hook up with your
Saved by the Bell cast member you can
actually say that you're worried but
kids now well yeah but just as a
gentleman I'm not one to kiss and tell
never however it wasn't a hookup but you
know I'm talking about it before she was
my girlfriend for a while Tiffani
Thiessen who looks like Kelly yeah yeah
there's funny because I went to regular
high school she's to where my um my
Letterman's jacket for my real high
school and stuff but now like she's my
dear friend and it's funny because our
kids actually play together so we'll get
together our kids play together and
stuff so it's I know ok alright well the
one thing I really do love about you
that I wanted to get to and make sure I
got to is y'all not everybody is who
they are on camera you know you see them
outside of work and you're like oh
you're not lovable at all here's an Isis
dude until I was like totally reading up
on you cuz I like to do my homework for
people coming on it made sense to me
that you even though you were filming
stood by the Bell you went to like
regular cuz I was a Saturday morning
thing right you went to like regular
school and you're like the only one that
went to public school right yeah I was
only the only one from my cast and for
the most part all the other child actors
that I knew everybody either was tutored
or homeschool their son but no I went to
a regular public high school 3,500 kids
Chula Vista High School shout-out
Spartans thank you but I mean I feel
very lucky because I I went to prom I
did homecoming I played sports and yeah
I had like a real high school experience
I just happen to have like a cool summer
job right really cool summer job yeah
yeah no I just thought whenever I read
that on you I was I was just captivated
by that because I was like well that
make sense that's why he's so cool and
down-to-earth
like I don't know you're super handsome
and you're AC Slater you could be
awesome I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this